when i was reading the quran you know
when i i found out that my dad was
muslim i didn't know that
yeah i found out that my dad was muslim
and he was in the streets
and he had a friend who was from new
york who was muslim
so they would always debate about quran
and you know
christianity and islam
my dad ended up taking taking his
shahada
through his friend like you know saying
why they were selling drugs but anyway
he ended up he ends up taking shahada
um yeah he ends up taking shahada
then you know he was still living their
life so he goes to prison
he told me why he was in prison like he
really
uh you know started practicing he really
stopped practicing was praying
all the time even was imam for a few you
know for for a while
while he was in prison and he said that
he prayed that allah made me muslim
he prayed that allah made me muslim and
and um
repair the relationship that he had
prepared while he was in prison
while he was in prison make me
he prayed allah make make me muslim make
my make my son
muslim and repair the relationship
between us
alhamdulillah and now now i can see why
i see my path so well
because i allah answered my
my father's my father's doer and
he allah allowed my father to see
my shahada and the same person who gave
him shahada gave me shot
man well that's unheard of
yeah so it's man don't that do it
the prayers that we make don't take them
lightly man like they
work yeah they work
make a lot of dudes you know right now
i'm having problems with my kids or
whatever and i was talking to a friend
he was like man get up for tahajud
get up for tihaja and beg your lord and
i was like
right man you're right
[Music]
[Music]
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively more than you're influencing
them positively
i think you need new friends
welcome back to another episode of the
three muslims podcast
we have the readers podcast in the dunya
and today we are joined by
a very real brother masha allah brother
nasheed salamu alaykum
that's good so why don't you begin
and just go straight into it talking
about uh your journey to islam because
we know that you're a rebirth
masha'allah
and we know that um you have some things
masha allah that i think
a lot of people wouldn't experience in
life and knowing that kind of
perspective
would really allow them to look at islam
in a new lens
um so i was raised
uh christian raised christian gram my
grandmother raised me
i was in church every sunday um
[Music]
and it was i guess about when i was like
13
14 she was like i had enough of you you
you don't listen
you two managed so she kicked me out
well she sent me to my mom
my mom was on the streets
she was on drugs uh on the streets so
i really didn't have a place to go i was
staying with her boyfriend
um her boyfriend's family
um so you know industries doing things
and it was um it was it was rap
music that you know i guess was like a
father to me you know
uh because you know no dad was dead no
guidance whatever so
rap music was like an influence in my
life um
[Music]
it was about 9192
when ks1 came out with an album called
uh
sex and violence i really got into that
album and
that album really made me question
christianity
you know what i mean because my
grandmother put me out
but i still needed you know god in my
life so i would find myself going to
church by myself
and uh it just didn't feel right for me
it just didn't feel right
so um i
i just found myself like gravitating
away from the church but i know
i still needed god in my life that that
album
uh sex and violence made me really
question christianity
and uh so i started calling my i
start saying i'm not christian i start
saying i'm not christian i'm not i don't
have a religion i just believe that this
this god i believe that i believe in god
but i don't have a religion
and that was my i was i had to be like
16 17 at the time um i stopped eating
pork
um and that was that was all hip-hop
that was ice cube ice cube
had a few songs that you know made me
stop eating pork
um
and this this girl that i was messing
with she said something about a quran
say something about muslims or whatever
anyway
that it just stuck in my mind i never
knew what a quran was
never no never heard of a quran and
around the same time i met a
pimp i started coming around a pimp
and
i i gravitated to him or he gravitated
to me because
we had some of them we had similar he
was older
of course but i guess he saw me
he saw himself in me because
women just attract i was attracted to
women and women
women were attracted to me like women
were easy for me
yeah women were easy for me so when i
was around him different women would
drop me off in cars
or he would see different women come by
the house i'm you know 17
16 17 at the time and he's like you know
women
cars or whatever i have no cars but it
was like you know
always there so he would see that and i
remember him saying
i'm going to make a man up out of you
and
he started to teach me things about
women that i didn't know that that uh
that was really intriguing to me
and i you know i was uh i i took i took
i took i took it in i took it i took it
all in um
[Music]
yeah so i'm i'm in that life with him
i'm seeing him bring women into his life
like he just meet women i've seen him
bring him into his life and
they're doing things that i've never saw
women do before for this guy he just met
him
so i was like really interested in what
he was talking about what he was he
wasn't just
talking to he was really giving me gain
on
you know on how to deal with women but
at the same time he had a quran
and he was a free mason uh
if you know anything about freemasonry
you know they they
they they believe in what i think uh
levels the 30t was a i don't know if he
was a 33rd level but after the 33rd
level or something like that you get a
quran like
it's a part of it so he had a quran and
he kept the quran like wrapped up in a
tower
a white tower and he would take it and
even open it up like
really slowly like it was something
precious and he would say
this book is very powerful right so
it you know that intrigued me i was
intrigued by that
so um we was always you know we would
get high together we would smoke weed
together
and one of those times um
i was high i went and picked up that
quran
open it up and i just you know let me
read let me see what's going on
why is this book so special so i opened
it up
brother i read something about the
hellfire
that scared the hell on me it was like i
put it i had to
like close it up and put it down it was
like the verses were screaming at me
i don't i don't know i can't
and it was like it was like
uh you know you reading how you read you
read to yourself
well i was reading to myself but it was
like
a group of people a group of
powerful people was like screaming at me
i've never experienced that before
anyway i closed the book
put it down and i was like man ain't
touching that book be right
that book is that book is powerful man
like for real
so anyway you know it goes on you know
we still doing he teaching me
he's showing me different things about
women or whatever and i was like okay
well let me try to get let me let me
let me see if this happened again i was
maybe i was you know just tripping
and the same exact thing happened when i
opened it up again
it was a different verse but it was the
same exact thing
so anyway of course that you know made
me
want to get into this book even more so
what i did was
and i at the time um every time him and
i had moved
in together i was like he had a room i
had a room you know he was going
half on reno whatever you know what i
mean um
i i had a few a few chicks that was
coming
you know to see me or whatever so you
know i was i was like 18 at the time
seven it was like 18 at the time so
you know life was life was great you
know life was good
but at the same time i needed god i know
i know that i needed god
so i started i picked up the quran and i
started reading it
from the beginning and i'm into it and
i'm i'm reading and i'm agreeing with
everything it says everything that i
understand
and then i got to the part that says you
can have two three or four wives i was
like oh yeah i'm just
[Laughter]
i didn't know what muslim was but i was
like yeah whatever this book say i'm
following because
i didn't have two or three four wives i
was like in it like i was
i was gone you know what i mean and um
anyway like i i i was still smoking weed
but i was reading a book uh like heaven
uh and
like i couldn't like that's all i wanted
to do
that's all i wanted to do was read the
book the girl that i was with
uh at the time she was like yo don't you
come on let's go i was like nah i'm good
like she
just wanted to pull me out to get me out
of this
this this this i don't know what i was
in but
the book was a part of me and i wanted
it
and i that verse what allah says and
uh they recognize the book like they
recognize their sons
like when a guy does come to me and they
recognize book that's how i felt i felt
like
i knew it like it was mine
um that
that whole situation with me in the
quran it took me out of
this that that pimp mode that i was in
anyway the pimp life was like a
uh it was a cold life man i i saw him
how he treated
women like you have to be
you have to be cold like you have to
have uh you have to be self
selfish to to really get into it and
that wasn't me
alhamdulillah i loved by by putting the
quran in my life at that time it pulled
me out of that hamdulillah so
it yeah by me reading the quran it just
like pulled me out of that life
and i the girl that i was with
100 who i married now who's what what
now
she's uh here and i just really went on
you know started the life with each
other we started a life with each other
and um
and you know we we're still here i'm
just 30 years later
but i i truly believe that um a lot of
the stuff
that he taught me i know for a fact a
lot of stuff that he taught me is the
reason why i'm still married to this
woman now
really that's pretty much the story
you know in a nutshell bro man yo
so you said forget level 1 through 33
i'ma just get the quran right now huh
yeah i don't i don't know what the
levels are about i don't know what you
got to go
for the levels but yeah i mean yeah just
start it right now let me get this quran
right now because it was like
you know i was agreeing with everything
it was talking about
everything that i understood i was i was
agreeing with like yeah this is it this
this got to be
it's got to be the one it's got to be it
i mean and then with me
me and my uh not my wife now but when we
were together
i would i would wake up every morning go
to the park smoke some weed
and read the crime that was my life man
like it was like a part of me
i got it i didn't i didn't want to do
anything else
[Music]
so you you briefly mentioned some stuff
about your pups when you were speaking
to me so we're going to go into that in
a bit
but you mentioned that some of the
things that you the pimp
taught you the freemasons taught you you
believe
are influential in why your marriage is
successful till today
right not everything but you still use
some of the things so you want to go
into some of those things some of those
lessons
okay so when you you know i'm saying
when you young
and you want multiple women
it's like believe that you have to lie
you have to lie
about you know what i'm saying what's
what you're doing
to women
[Laughter]
you know and that's what i was thinking
as a young man you know i'm saying i was
thinking as a young man like you have to
lie
nah the pimp was like he hurt me i was
uh
and i was talking to somebody on the
phone and i believe i was telling her
you know
that i got this on my phone oh i'm i'm
this age
and he was like man stop lying to them
hoes man like
really he was like stop lying to them
hoes because
when
you're trying and in their minds you
want to be
something different than other men are
not
like like those those that's what those
men do you
you have to be different from them and
and that's that's that's one of the
things you told me you know you have to
uh
yeah you have to be different so lying
is not a part of it
because they know that every dude is
trying to lie to get between their pants
they they that's that's the goal for
them they're trying to get in their
pants
he was like you want more than that
women i mean i see now
why you won't want for that you know he
wanted to exploit them you know what i
mean
but what he told me was um you know you
you you want more than what's between
their pants you want them to
to give themself to you entirely
so you have to be different from what
other dudes are teaching oh
telling them so that's that's one of the
things that uh
that i've always you know kept to the
front of my brain
and i really i think it has helped me in
my relationship
and it has helped me with you know
having
uh with because i have two wives
and i was i was always transparent about
you know to my wife about what i'm doing
um because now
she met me and i was with a pimp she met
me and i was you know had a couple
had a couple women but when we got
married when he got into it
her story was well i'm so in love with
you i can't really see you with nobody
else
huh what
you can't see me with nobody else you
know who i was you know who i
am so anyway for uh for years i tried to
play that game
and i think for a lot of us um
it's just in us to have more than one
woman
like polygamy is just a part of some of
us
and i'm one of those i'm one of those
people because i tried to
quiet for her for my love for her i
tried to quiet that
down that that inner
you know some that part of me that wants
another woman i tried to quiet it down
but it
and stayed quiet for a couple of years
that's it not
i would say this if
you know you're looking to get another
wife
you if if you are scared or fear of
losing the wife that you're with don't
even try it
because it's a possibility that you
could go that she could leave
don't don't even try it because it's
it's not just about
sex man you know i'm saying it's not
just about sex you have to know who you
are
can you really deal with another one um
and that's one of the things that the
pimp taught me is how to manage
not only women but the emotions of women
because it's you know i'm saying it's
like really it's
it's an emotional roller coaster that
you as a man cannot
jump on when when two women are involved
when more than one woman is involved
it's an emotional emotional roller
coaster that you cannot jump on
you just let them you know you know
roller coaster you go don't let them do
that
you don't do that at all we you we you
can't
because you have to uh you have to
manage that
and that's like i said that's one of the
things that we talked it's almost like
it's almost like we are the roller
coaster
and they're just riding it okay yeah
that's it oh i look at it that's how i
look because i'm still in control
that's it that's it don't that's it you
can't ride your own ride man
you know you know what i'm saying like
you can't stream on your own right you
know
yeah yeah yeah yeah going to the brother
going to the what are some of the things
you
you experience in terms of like handling
emotions
um so within the first
and so i've been i've had
this is this i have had two lives twice
the first one didn't work out because i
don't think i was ready for it
um and i noticed from the first
six months to a year is hell
like it is hell um
because your first wife is trying to get
used to you leaving
or just having another woman in your
life you know what i'm saying
and a lot of that a lot of that is
they're sharing a sexual partner like
she don't she's sharing her sexual part
that's something that they have to get
over so
i'm when i'm getting uh
what you call it i'm getting um stress
from the first wife
because you know i'm leaving or whatever
then i'm getting stressed from the from
it's it's all fun and new the second
wife is you know trying to make you feel
comfortable but at the same time
she has that same feeling that she's
sharing another man and she's
complaining about time and
she she's trying to get you to behave a
certain way
and if you don't behave this way she's
gonna leave um
stay who you are that's stay true to who
you are you know what i mean let me
of course just compromise them uh
but stay true to who you are in those
situations man because
uh if one can get you to
be the way they want them to be they
think they have power over you
and i'm saying it's it's not a power
game
it's not a power game not for you or
them like we have to do this together
we have to do this together but don't
don't don't allow
one of them to make you to feel like
they have power over you by doing
exactly what they want you to do
you know what i'm saying express i mean
like i said you can compromise
but don't compromise to a pac to the
point where it's changing
who you are naturally because you you're
going to go back to who you are
like that's it's going you're going to
go back to who you are and then she's
mad at you because
you made these promises and and now
you're doing exactly what you said you
wouldn't do
i i got a question um you said
that uh for some dudes
they shouldn't get with the second wife
throw by fourth wife etc
uh how would a dude know if he's ready
for this like let's say financially you
know he's
he's got the money for it let's say um
his chick is she's not 100 with it but
she's not against it
how would he know that he's ready for it
so i say if you would if you're with a
woman
and like
you feel that she's doing oh she's a
she's pleasing you in every way you know
she you cook
she cooks for you everything everything
that you need not necessarily cooking
but
she's pleasing you in every way possible
and
when you're when you're not with her
you're not thinking about another one
like you don't when when somebody
uh when somebody flirts at you you don't
flirt back or
uh those those old numbers you got on
your phone you ain't trying to
you know contact them and say i miss you
or whatever
if if if all that if if if those
desires are curved with her in your life
keep her keep her that that that's one
way i can say
and another way is if if if you just
fear that she like i said if you feel
she might leave
if you go get another way and you know i
mean it'll hurt you
if she does leave don't don't even
attempt to try to get another wife
because
it's she will being polygamy is a lonely
life man i'm telling you polygamy even
though yeah you got multiple wives but
it's a lonely life because you never
have time
you understand like you never have time
for yourself and and that's why it's
along your life everything is
uh yeah you you're constantly accosted
with families different issues of family
or whatever
so you're you don't have time for
yourself you have to
uh somehow make time for yourself
because it's a lonely life really
did i answer that yeah that was that was
perfect actually in
my bed i'm i'm legit writing notes yo
rami man could you relate to what what
uh brother nishid was speaking
on before uh angel's question how like
you're always gonna return back to who
you really are
that stuck with me when he said that
because if you don't voice what you
really want
and you try to change for a person you
might you might get them to think you're
how they are but you're still you you're
still going to be you know how you think
at the end of the day
and it's going to come the truth always
comes to the surface sooner or later so
you might as well just be authentic from
day one
exactly everything you said everything
you said instantly clicked with me
uh subhan allah because from what i've
learned for what i've been taught it's
always you know be clear cut from the
beginning
right maybe not first conversation like
okay i'm gonna be polygamous that's it
but like you know mention it make it
clear from the beginning and if she
doesn't want that and you do
just walk away and if you're okay being
monogamous
okay that's cool but and it's like
subhanallah like everything
i've been taught everything i've
experienced myself is like
subhanallah this is facts it's
unfortunate because this is something
that we're not taught
it's upon allah like the brother had to
learn it from a pimp
i have to learn it from a pimp man we're
not taught this
normally but this is what we're doing
here alhamdulillah so uh
there's one thing that is bothering me
though so the freemason what was his
relationship with the quran other than
being a freemason was he a muslim did he
read it or did he just say this is
precious and like
that's it i don't know i don't
i really we just said it was a special
book i don't even know if people's 33rd
degree
like because he would see when he would
see other uh freemasons like he would
you know give him this
special handshake and or he would you
know use
that different language what was it one
of them was a
man you shine like i see light on you
that's that's one of them
like i see light you know um i don't
know
um but because and but it couldn't be it
couldn't have been
uh too serious because he ended up
giving me the quran anyway
like he was like you know you keep that
that's yours like
that so
like i see my path to islam i see
my clear path to islam you know with the
quran with
uh and and allah allowed me to meet my
wife
you know what i'm saying who came from
like where i came from so we like don't
really know each other
um it's like truly a blessing
but when i became
when when i was reading the quran you
know when i i
found out that my dad was muslim i
didn't know that
yeah i found out that my dad was muslim
and he was in the streets
and he had a friend who was from new
york who was muslim
so they would always debate about koran
and you know
christianity and in islam
my dad ended up taking taking his
shahada
through his friend like you know saying
why they were selling drugs
but anyway he end up he ends up taking
shahada
um yeah he ends up taking shahadah
then you know he was still living the
life so he goes to prison
he told me why he was in prison like he
really
uh you know start practicing really
stopped practicing was praying
all the time even was imam for a few you
know for
for a while while he was in prison and
he said that
he prayed that allah make me muslim
he prayed that allah made me muslim and
and um
repair the relationship that he had
prepared while he was in prison
while he was in prison
make me he prayed allah make make me
muslim make my make my son muslim
and repair the relationship between us
alhamdulillah and now now i can see why
i see my path so well
because i allah answered my
my father's my father's doer and
he allah allowed my father to see
my shahada and the same person who gave
him shahada gave me a shot
don't take them lightly man like they
work yeah
they work make a lot of dudes you know
right now i'm having problems with my
kids or whatever and i was talking to a
friend and he was like
man get up for tahaju get up for tahaju
and beg your lord and i was like you're
right man
you're right so yeah those those dudes
work man for real
mashallah the prophet saw they sent him
he said that dura is the weapon of the
believer
subhanallah and when you think about it
i mean it couldn't be like man that's
the truth that is the truth subhanallah
it's it's tough and it's it's
unfortunate how many people
uh not only do they not make dua but
they fall into this mindset that allah
is not going to help me
but allah man while he was locked up he
made dua for his son
and subhanallah like and i was you see i
was out there in the world i was
i was out there like i was about to go i
would've i was about to go down a path
that ain't no coming back from you know
what i'm saying because i was with the
pimp
he was something i never did it never
did cocaine but he was you know start
cocaine and
you know he had other habits i've never
got into those habits because
i those doers activated those doers
activated right on time
so it took me like it took me off
another path and for a while
while i was smoking weed and reading the
quran like i couldn't my speech was i
couldn't talk
i promise i couldn't i don't know i
couldn't speak so what i said what i did
but something just inspired me to start
writing and uh
at that time like like after i left out
the pimp house
me and my wife got an apartment together
or whatever
um i started writing poetry and
i would recite the poetry to tell you
how i feel what was telling would tell
you what was going on
humbly luck but yeah that that started
my writing
marshall what do you mean you couldn't
write like go into this
you couldn't speak you couldn't speak
yeah like what do you mean by that i
couldn't
you know you have thoughts that come to
your mind yeah damn i couldn't
it was only like one or two words or
whatever like i couldn't
i mean i could communicate you know to
tell you hey pick up that or
go get this but when it comes to sitting
down and having a conversation with you
i i i didn't i don't know i don't maybe
it was the weed
i hear some banging weeds or something
like that but
while while that was going on i was
still heavily
reading the quran i was still heavily
and you started writing right go into
that i want to know about you know tell
the viewers some of your books because
we're going to put the links in the
description for all of your books for
all of our viewers but
go into some of your your books do a
little bit of a quick synopsis of the
plot
and uh yeah okay so
when i started writing um i started
writing poetry
and i would
i i had a whole i had a group of dudes
that i was with
a few dudes one of them still my best
friend
who were muslim who like we all became
muslim around the same time
so and we were smoking weed too so you
know that's what it was
but i would write poems and then i would
just go
and like perform them in front of the
dough boards you know what i mean
and uh that it was like really
that was entertaining very it was very
entertaining they were like really good
and i was talking about allah i was
talking about you know the quran i was
talking about
uh yeah how our situations
as black people you know needs to get
better and god is going to make that
better if you only believe in him
those kind of things that's what i was
talking about so i did that for years
um um writing poetry and uh
and that went to my writing poetry like
kind of
fell off but i'm still a writer so i
started writing um
books i got inspired to write a book
just
just just recently though well in 2014
i uh i started writing a book
my first i wanted to start writing books
just to
give doubt just for entertainment
for entertainment of course but also to
give doubt to let people know that
yeah i'm muslim my wife covers up my
children you know cover up we go to the
massive but my life
or the same struggles that i have is
just like
your christian household just like your
jewish household
you know what i mean like uh you know we
hurt we got we we go through the same
issues our children
do the things they want to that's what i
wanted to tell people i wanted to bring
people
inside of the muslim house at home and
um
and and and let them know that you know
we we got those same issues
so the first book i wrote is uh her
justice
and justice is a married dude
who who's he's a therapist and
uh he's you know a kind of attractive
dude so he always has different women
coming in
his wife is you know he don't want her
to work so she stays at home
um so she stays at home
but she's tired of it uh
he's an attractive dude so he has a
nemesis i
created a nemesis for him uh
which is a beautiful woman who who wants
him and he she tries to get him so the
story ends up
it just ends up telling that story of
she the
the lady is trying to get him and the
woman
uh his wife is trying to uh
leave i don't know it's it humbly lies
since i
wrote it i've had nothing but great
reviews nothing but great reviews from
from muslims and non-muslims men and
women like nothing nothing but great
rules
um it has a part two to it that i just
put out um
in january uh actually the end of
december
um yeah part two to that i also
have a book called halal nympho yeah
halal nympho um
that's the best kind of going on that
one
what what's that about so so men
i was always thinking about like what
hap what would happen if you know
uh nympho decides that hey islam is a
is a great religion let me become muslim
like how would she behave how would this
nimple behave in this line
so i wrote a book about it this is a
short story marcelo it's a short story
and nothing but great reviews from that
also um
it just it tells the story of a dude
who's married to her who ends up
marrying her
um and he can't handle all the sex
that that she that she's given them
so be careful what you asked for that's
that's what i thought
that's how i started though i be careful
what you ask
for because you may get it because she
wants sex
you know full six times a day
it even comes to to keep her please they
even bring in toys
into the relationship just to keep her
pleased
yeah so it just i really i really wrote
the book for
you know thought provoking i want to you
know
i want people to start thinking about
that i'll really you know have a
conversation about
if how and you know how for leaders to
say how will we deal with this
if i'm sure it has happened before
how a a how an imam would deal with
a couple coming to them say hey man my
wife won't too much sex i can't give it
to her
i want to divorce could you imagine that
man if she wants sex all the time and i
can't i can't handle it
i can't handle it man like i can't
yeah so i got that one her loud info um
no i'm thinking i'm working on a book uh
actually i should have a book out by the
end of the month it's called a poetry
night
sorry poetry i love addiction poetry
night um okay
love addiction poetry night uh yeah so
so is that what i'm doing yeah it's it's
exciting man it's exciting man
and the response that i'm getting from
the community is really really good
really good alhamdulillah it's good here
so is the last one a poetry book or does
it just how they poetry in the title
okay so how i describe it is it's a love
story
because i've been coined to be a romance
writer
it's a love story with
but it's a it's a love story wrapped
with a love i'm sorry
it's a poetry book wrapped with a love
story
it's a poetry book rap with a love story
so what you're doing you're following
this couple
um you're following this couple who is
dealing with
issues in their relationship and they're
they're they're doing they're dealing
with these issues inside of a poetry
venue
both is their first time going to a
poetry venue
so i really so i really tried to paint
the picture of
how i felt when i first went into a
portrait video
you know i said i hope yeah i hope the
reader when
when they're reading it that they can be
there that they really want to
be at a poetry video so you're following
them through a poetry venue and they're
listening to poetry
at the same time they're dealing with
their issues um
yeah that's powerful that's powerful i
got a question for you
yes so you're writing this book where
you're basically
uh speaking about being in love and
stuff like that so what do you think
about being in love
like is that is that possible to be in
love with multiple women because
i mean nowadays when you see the uh
these dating coaches and
you know the dudes that are actually
talking about spinning plates and having
multiple women and stuff like that
they're trying to run
uh the pimp game some of them might be
pimps
you know a lot who have them god knows
best but uh some of them
are not you know they're just kind of
regurgitating what they said so
they advocate that you have to be cold
like you said where the pimple is very
cold to all these chicks
so do you think
that is possible to be in love with
multiple women or do you think it's uh
you have to be cold
all right you don't have to be called
the prophet saddam was our best example
and he was smooth mashallah like they
they loved him and he wasn't cold how
can you be in love
you can love all of them for different
reasons so yes i think you can
for different so that's what being in
love means to you
loving someone for a specific reason
yeah well for me for me yeah um okay
because you know i mean i
i love my wives i do i love them
and and i love them for for different
reasons
of course i love them because who they
are but
i know that i can get one
something out of this one that i can't
get from the other one
and i love all that about and i love how
they allow me to be me
yeah that's um that's interdependent so
you have people who are codependent
where they depend on the other person
you have people who are independent or
they don't depend on anyone then you got
people who are interdependent where they
are
independent but they see the value in
the other people
as well that's me yeah yeah i'm doing
now
that's it that's it but what would you
say to the dudes who
say that uh or the chicks as well the
chasers will
the ones who say that um it's one thing
to love someone and then another thing
to be in love with someone
i i would say man listen um to be in
love like i think everybody needs to
experience that
everybody needs to experience to be in
love because
i know i would i would say that i
believe that our
men us being in love is not like a woman
you know what i mean like um like you've
never heard
you never heard a man say to a woman
you're so romantic
you just you don't hear that women say
that that's something that
that they say to us because they live in
these this world of flowers and
candy and you know i'm saying that's
that's that's what it is to be in love
for them
but for us i believe
when we're in love we're able to well
i know i am i'm able to accomplish stuff
like i'm not able to accomplish things
like i feel because i
that part of my life is is complete
and i'm able to uh
dive into things more completely
yeah i'm able to dive into things more
completely so
that's what it is to be in love for me
and i i think everybody needs to
experience that
yes at least like uh
what's saying that uh getting married is
completing 50
of your deen yeah all right so now i
need you to
i listen go i need y'all go there with
me right now right quick all right we're
gonna go there
now listen i just thought about this the
other day and i hope i can think of it
but
okay islam
comes from the word peace right
yeah hey i can't even think about it
so islam comes from the root word peace
yeah and
marrying someone completes
that peace complete your deen
that's it no it's real bro that's real
because
you feel like there's this there's this
requirement that's met and fulfilled
and now you as a man you can do other
things can you do it without it
yes but you still feel that
insufficiency
can you can you can you continue living
life without meeting that of course
people are doing it right there are so
many prophets that never got married
but is it in my opinion sunnah
recommended no
no yeah right yeah yeah so let me let me
share a little personal story because i
feel like it hits home
especially with your story brother um
when i was a jaihin
and and i was uh not muslim i had
i think i had two serious relationships
that lasted
several years um a few girls in between
here and there you know with the brakes
whenever we would like split
but the entire time that i was with
these women i was always suppressing the
idea or
or the the desire to want to be with
other women
it was always there and i always had
other women you know basically trying to
talk to me basically throwing it at me
and i was always trying to be this uh
just trying to be loyal you know and
loyalty starts from within so
um not many people have that tree i'm
not trying to say anything here but
what i am saying is that i neglected
that
and then when i was with the last woman
that i was with her and i were engaged
then uh things kind of fell apart and
then after that
you know i realized okay i need to take
some time apart from women
but i also realized that i was making a
huge mistake
in the previous years by denying that uh
that innate feeling that i had of
wanting to be with multiple women
so i got to the point where it's like
before coming to islam i actually
started talking
to a lot of women i think i had um
i had four right there on the man
four on the man where it's like
everything was about to go down
and subhanallah that's actually when i
came on to the quran and i just
dropped all of them to be able to focus
on that
but all right but the the whole thing
i'm trying to get at here
is that with this whole dean thing with
the
completing 50 like that honestly that
can be more true
because i'm here listen i don't have a
wife
rami is engaged in sha allah he will be
married soon
fayette is married you brother
you're married as well you have two
wives you said right
bro i have no wives um
not really talking to anyone serious
right now and
i still put it in my mind like no i'm
gonna get these things done i'm still
accomplishing this but
exactly what you said is like i still
have this
desire to be with women and it's always
there i
sometimes i might talk to myself and be
like you know what like even if i don't
get married like it's cool as long as
i'm
uh pursuing my purpose and i am on dean
with allah subhanahu wa the other but
then bro
when you start thinking about them walls
you start thinking about women
it's like oh yeah that all goes out the
door and you you get that tunnel vision
you know and then
you start losing them bro you start
losing it i know you know this
i know you know this every man knows
this um but the whole point of this
what i'm trying to say is that
there will be times where
because i don't have a woman i would
literally try to rationalize with myself
like oh you know what
um just get with this girl she's she
just wants to be monogamous
you know it's okay you can do this it'll
complete half your deen
and uh you'll be good you know you'll
take care of that aspect but it's like
a mind stretched by new experiences
can't go back to its old dimensions
i already realized like damn like
we kind of want to be with multiple
women so
it's it's um listen i don't even know
where i'm trying to get it i lost the
point like halfway in
i just kept going to be honest with
y'all
well i'll make it easy for you man man
i'll make it easy for you but i can't
say this
list and and i want to
like my intentions is to write a book
next and what i want to put one of the
things that i want to put in this
book is that when dudes when we get
married
you have to make that woman feel
feel like she's the only woman
in your life without ever saying
it and i think that's what a lot of
dudes we we mess up when we you know
we call ourselves giving game or
whatever you know those those
really romantic moments where you you
tell i want no other woman it's all you
it's all you
she's gonna remember that but i think
that's when you say it
that's what gets us in trouble like you
have to find a way
to make her feel like
she's the only woman for you and she is
like she is
i just gotta go get another you know
what i mean
so that so so when when
when you do decide to get another one
she can't ever say that you that you
said hey you said that i was
only one not don't ever don't ever say
that don't
don't don't put yourself don't cut your
leg off
you don't say it because then you can't
walk and get another way well you can
but then it's to be
you know confusion about it yeah
so you said that being polygamous is a
very lonely life
because you you tend to not have much
time for yourself so what do you do to
make time for yourself
well i'm i'm a writer so that's i i just
well you know i'm always working because
you got to support right
so but i mean as for you though i'm i i
believe i
um i put
all those those emotions that i can't
really show to nobody in my writing
um somebody works out one of y'all goes
to the gym right
y'all work out all of us do yes that's
the thing i
that y'all i think y'all probably you
know push that out i
just recently started back you know
trying to do something trying to work
out and
it helps it just helps it because it's
something that you're doing for yourself
it's
it's me timing what they call it a
self-improvement or
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah self-care yeah don't care
so would you say that uh that that alone
time
is gonna look different for each man oh
yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah
yeah i mean that's how i see it i i see
polygamy as a lonely life but you know
other other people you may not because i
like being alone like i really enjoy
like being alone that sometimes i go
work out of town
and you know i leave my family here and
there's days i don't even call them like
everything okay they don't call me
they're okay because i i like i just
like being alone
yeah you've uh you've prayed with your
wives right
yes like with them together how does
that feel
wait hold on no no you know what i gotta
make that happen i have listen listen
bro
let me let me let me spit some game
right now i was reading
i was reading a book uh by uh dr omar
zaid
and he was saying that we all know that
as men
we're the wali right we are we have
authority over our
women right after allah and his
messenger we have
the highest authority over anyone else
but
with that authority comes responsibility
and in the same way
you should be her imam and when i read
that i was like what does he mean you
should be your imam
and it's like thinking about it's like
i've known so many relationships and
dynamics and marriages where it's like
the woman is more religious than the man
now
there's no i'm not saying this is the
sister's fault obvious
because she's on deen cool alhamdulillah
but the man's not on dean and that's a
problem
and they don't have the barakah or the
blessings of allah
now flip that over if the man's on dean
moore and she sees that
it keeps the family unit together and
she knows that and she sees that because
what seven days out of the month she
can't
pray because she's on she's on the rug
but
she sees you on it 24 7. and it keeps
her on it too
there's no better feeling than you
praying and you know she's right behind
you right beside you
and you're leading basically the whole
unit to allah
yeah i got to make that happen man i'm
thinking about it because i've been
married to
one for 30 years i've been married for
one for 10.
and that whole time
i want to say once but other people was
there because we would add you know some
event or whatever
yeah yeah inshallah bro make it bro the
hajjud
just y'all no one else no kids just
dialing in and it's there's no greater
feeling bro i agree with that
i do agree with that that's what i'm
saying i pray with them but in separate
homes
together i pray with them but never just
both of them together
and me out for now i just i ain't do
that man i gotta
that's it
[Laughter]
just imagine that bro just imagine and
it's like
if they if they're really on dean they
love allah then
no woman should have an issue with that
bro yes
i'm really blessed at that because they
really love
allah man they love this dean for real
i got a question for you bro how much
time are you spending with each of your
wives
women and because for the past uh
you know after pandemic i've been
working at night time
in the night so you know i don't sleep
with nobody
my day's off i mean i'm i'm always in
one house
but you know i don't she's here
and when i'm here she's at work cause
she works from home
so i'm here but um i really don't spend
time so
it's not a lot of time with with you so
if you were to
give an estimate would you say like on
average a day
because i know you have children as well
you have you've been married for
30 years you have children you
definitely yes
yeah they gone though like everybody
well my daughter came back which
he were kids so my daughter's here
but uh the kids are gone like we're we
got grand
we got grandkids now once y'all love
masha'allah
all right so on estimate let's say with
the two wives
are you spending like two hours
with them a day maybe one hour with each
of them
okay like on rotation it's yeah it's
some rotations so
um what it was what it what it was
before you know um i was everything was
normal
it was three days here four days there
and i would stay four days where the
kids were and my other wife was okay
with that you know the kids need to see
you
um so that's what it was but now it's
as far as time it's like a day
it's like a day of peace for both of
them because i'm working
my the hours i work and then i work six
five six days a week so uh yeah bye bye
i'm spinning with both of them yeah but
maybe like one hour a day right
not more more yeah okay okay
yeah but i'm saying i'm saying i don't
see like i don't see them every day
okay but when you're with them it's like
an hour or two hours next
four hours because that's why i spoke to
him i like you know
getting in no conversation i'm doing
that i'm doing that
see for me it's it's it's more than sex
with like i just
really like women you know
i just really i didn't know yeah
i mean of course it can be you know
saying if you were
uh if you just you know got a high uh
sex
if you're high in sex you you of course
you can have more than one life but it
can't just be about sex when you have to
talk about having multiple lives yeah
going into that bro you made a video
about you know keep your d out of her
and
that video went viral man that's how i
found you and
alhamdulillah that was that was some
solid advice but go into that because a
lot of brothers here think
okay we know when we get in the cat when
we get married
the first thing that becomes halal is
sex so isn't that isn't it all about
that
it's important but it's it's necessary
but it's not the end-all be-all it's not
everything so go into that
[Music]
all right so we're going back to what
the pimp taught me and
um that was probably
like you know rule number one because
i'm young you know i'm young and
you know her booty fine she got all the
nice curves you know what i mean
i want to hit that like you know i said
i want to have sex with that
but what he was telling me was that's
what other people do
that's what other dudes do you have to
be different
and and and you do that by
not having sex with her all the time
like
it's like in the beginning it was all
done bring
i saw him meet two women right
and he met these like it was like a week
apart or two weeks i'm not
but he met these two women and
he was doing the hair he was doing their
feet
he hadn't had sex with him at all hadn't
had sex with him
you know pimps are pretty man like
they're real pretty so
and i think that's part of the
attraction for the women like they're
into he he knows me
he he knows who i am because he's pretty
too well anyway
he was doing her feed he was you know
doing her hair
uh teaching her teaching her things that
she
really didn't know and this went on for
like a month or two and he hadn't even
had sex with neither one of them
and they were lit they were in the house
with him like they were one would be in
the room
like one night and then the other one
would come out and sleep on the couch
and then the other one would go i'm like
no sex how the hell do you do it how do
you do this
so i saw that it worked what i saw what
he was telling me was work
don't don't put your don't have sex with
him because
that's what all the other dudes doing
and women know
that that's what you want women know
that that's what you want so you
i mean i i this i think i think it's
about vibes
like uh you know you're talking to a
woman and
she she can pick up a vibe if you want
sex or not
all right she can put my vibe but if she
doesn't get that vibe from you
talking for you just for five minutes if
she don't get that vibe that you wanna
have sex
she's going to be intrigued and want to
want to know more want to
uh want to see what else you're talking
about
so um i would tell
dudes to re read more
so you can have more to talk about not
just to reject
regurgitate the the stuff that you read
but reading
expands your brain it opens up your mind
to different concepts
yeah you know i'm saying so read more so
when you're talking to her
you can talk more than just about what
every other dude is talking about
and and uh you know
you won't you won't have to have sex
with her because she she'll want to give
it to you
and that's what you want but and at the
same time at the same time
she gotta know that you would knock the
dust off that thing you know i mean like
she you you will give it to her all the
time but you don't have to say that
you know i'm saying like you don't have
to say that you that you would do that
but you know keep keep keep it out of
her keep it out of her
for a while especially until you see
crazy because
all of them are crazy okay i'm sorry
they're not crazy
[Music]
but it's different levels of crazy you
know what i'm saying but if you keep
your
you keep your penis out of them long
enough
you'll see what level of crazy she is
because once the penis gets involved
she's going to go she's going to take
that level of crazy to another level
yeah you don't you done then you lost
yeah
yeah there was a hadith with the prophet
saws saying that women are like
well you think about a woman the first
woman was made from
adam alassalam's rib right adam's rib
and it was a crooked rib so
a woman's literally a crooked rip that's
what the prophet i'm saying it's like
they're not straightforward they're not
consistent they're not the way men
are wired to logically rationalize the
world
and they're crooked and what happens to
a crooked rip if you try to straighten
it
you'll break it you might as well leave
it as it is and just
accept that and learn to work with that
yeah
that's it but and but once you put the
once you give it a d
it's over bro
once you give a d i mean i really want
to see i can't wait
you know till we make it to jenna
inshallah you know what i mean
and i'm able i want to see like what
happened sexually
like because i think something spiritual
happens like you're
you're giving her you're she's giving
herself to use you giving yourself to
her
i think something like when you break up
a part of like y'all still have a part
of each other that makes any sense like
y'all still have a part of each other
with you which which makes her crazy
which makes her even crazier yeah
that makes sense a lot of people call it
soul ties or something like that spirit
eyes or something like yeah
what advice would you have for a lot of
brothers that are going through a
breakup or heartbreak or stuff like that
and they're just
they're so attached to the
comfort scenario that they used to have
their world with this woman who's no
longer part of it and she's not
good for him but he can't come to terms
with the fact that is the past just move
on
and they feel that thing that you're
talking about that soul tie that like
connection that it's still there and
so it feels so real but they don't know
you know how to like cope with that so
do you have
any experience with that for any
brothers in our in our audience that are
probably going through that right now
so the okay i had i have
two breakups in my life that i can
remember and the first one
was you uh i guess high school or during
that time of high school
or whatever yo every dude that i know
had that breakup
[Music]
yes oh my god man
man i feel so weak to even say this to
y'all man but i wanted to kill myself
man like
i wanted to step out in front of a car
and kill myself that's just how
how bad it was i um i went to speak to
my mom about it
i remember crying i was cheering me
my mom was like hurt right here i was
like yes
man i told my mom when i had my first
breakup she
smacked me across the edge she said get
over it
[Music]
i'm all real with it man but i'm real
with it okay so so
okay that's the first one i went through
but any that same
chick who broke my heart
i met with the pimp
he taught me some game and when she came
back
she was she was in the saddle like she
was down like
she wanted to go turn tricks for me like
it was like that
like it like flipped after she broke my
heart
pimp taught me game and when she came
back she went
she wanted to turn tricks for me
marshall i mean i can't take my
shoulders
no i get that bro i get that because
it's like
it's we all know that it's easy to start
good with a woman but it's still
possible to like start
bad and be weak but then reclaim that
but it's so much easier to just do it
right from the jump anyway
yeah absolutely yeah yeah so what was
different
what was different when the the chick
came back because i know
obviously your frame changed obviously
your mindset changed but like
what could you say that you could
remember that was tangibly different
what game did you use on her
[Music]
hold up let me get my notebook bro
i'm just playing go ahead i had a i had
a
i don't care attitude you know you hear
she was finding her oh my gosh she was
fine
she was older than me too so she man
and the thing okay so um
[Music]
like i told you like the chicks was
coming to see me
and uh she was one of the one of the
chicks who found out where i was and
came over to see me
and uh the pimp used to cut hair like
people used to come to the hood we was
like in the hood and he would cut hair
people's hair
on the front porch and she came up and
walked up while i was there
he was like you know her i saw her the
other day like i tried to holla and she
wouldn't give me no play or whatever you
know what i'm saying
so that was one of the things that she
was mad
man i want to say her name but anyway
so um what was different was i had a i
don't care attitude like
it's it's whatever you know before i was
i was telling about love all the time
you know
yeah i mean i was buying a roses and
stuff like that but i had
i had this i was still doing i was still
saying i was i had i don't care attitude
but you know i was still like showing
that i care it was a standoff attitude i
don't care it was like a standoff
attitude
and i guess that just attracted them
more like that that really attracted him
more
um yeah that's what i could say i was
that was different than i can remember
if i gave him more thought i'll probably
think of some more stuff
damn when i went through that first
breakup man
i was incapacitated i was like bro i
couldn't eat
i couldn't sleep i was depressed i also
wanted to kill myself for months for
so long bro and man if you looked at
like my youtube search history
it was all how to get your ex back how
to get your ex back
how to deal with the breakup well all
this stuff and it was so pathetic it was
the worst time in my life
but something that's anyone that's going
through it the man you become
afterwards phenomenal inshallah
the man that you become afterwards well
she doesn't deserve that man anyway
a hundred percent man 100 100 once you
become that man
you stop caring about like oh she did
this to me she did that to me
but you stopped caring about getting her
back you stopped caring about revenge
you start you stop caring about all that
because your
your goal your focus your frame is so
it is so far off from that because the
place you you move to especially when
you have a lot in the equation
and the fact that you have leveled up
now means the caliber of woman that you
can attract now
is far superior than the lowly woman
that you had before
i don't let you want you back though but
she wants you back that woman that left
you
that's true that's what i was gonna say
unless she uses that as fuel and
inspires her to level up too
but that's that's a far you know that's
that's rare if you have that cool but
not many men do yeah okay so i
i went through a divorce too um like i
told you i was married
i had two i went and the first one just
didn't work out
even though i had a wife that divorce
hurt man like for real we we was just
married not even a year probably but
it i don't know maybe that's why it's
uh a lust is that um it's it's
it's permissible but it's hated yeah i
know
you understand you feel like when you
divorce
it feels like you're i guess yeah it
feels like you're just pleasing a love
because it hurts man like you
and i couldn't show to her that i was
feeling because i had a wife you know
what i mean
i couldn't
tell us about your relationship with
your father now you know if you're
comfortable bro whatever you feel like
okay so my mom um i got
i got my grandmother raised like drugs
drugs took over my uh my family like
my grandmother who raised me all five of
her kids was on crack at the same time
like that's crazy like you mean like
and my mom was caught up in you know she
was out there in the streets
uh like i don't i never
[Music]
i start i lived with her when i became a
teenager
um like like 17 like she had a little
apartment and i started living with her
for only a month or two because when i
got 18 i moved with the pimp
um but yeah that's my baby though like
you know
she was never there but um when i got
older when i became a teenager she was
always there
uh you know giving me giving me advice
whatever
uh giving me advice on the girls like
the girl who broke my heart
like she was like i don't like her this
was before she broke my heart
she was like i don't like like mom what
you talking about she's fine yummy like
look at him
uh yeah so but she was she was there
when i was a teenager
yeah you know trying out there in the
street she she was always there
much i loved it yeah that's my baby she
she uh
she passed in 97. she got she was able
to see her
her first my daughter her first
grandchild
um yeah but after that you know she uh
drugs and alcohol really you know slowed
her heart down and she died
so i'm sorry no no no
no bro it's not it's not easy bro it's
not it's really not easy
um what about your dad my dad's still
around man
i talk to him i talk to him often uh
one of his prayers was to make our
relationship better and that's my buddy
like that's
my dad is my buddy man in fact i need to
fly
i'm going to fly down there and see him
probably next month just to spend some
time with him because you know they get
no
that's my buddy yeah
you know we got any uh closing remarks
before we close it off
yeah the last thing that i wanted to
throw in here man
because when you were talking about uh
that you like
talking to your women and you know you
actually like having that conversation
with them
i thought i was the only one i thought i
was alone on this and
my old friends in the past we would talk
and
they would they would think i was crazy
everything i was backwards because every
every kid back then used to have this uh
i don't know where they got it but they
had this understanding of like oh you
gotta smash as quick as possible
like first day first day um
second day third and if you don't get it
by the third then you should just pretty
much throw it to the curb
because like she's just putting out at
that point and
man like i'm not saying that i would
talk to them in like a
uh like a friend type of way i would
still be
uh seductive and romantic with them but
it's like i would take my time
with it sometimes i take like yeah
sometimes i take like a month
one time i remember the first girl that
i ever had
relations with that was the one who i
lost my virginity to
uh i think i took like
six to eight months and it wasn't
it wasn't no friend vibe it was like
real
like that real tight vibe and i i do
think now that you're saying it
it just re-emphasizes the fact of like
why
she has such a pull towards me when in
reality there were a lot of other dudes
way more attractive than i was at the
time
that were trying to holler at her yet
she wasn't giving them any play at all
you thought you were crazy for that bro
yeah yeah same bro
right yeah yeah i mean yeah that's
that's what it is man
for me i can say that it's always been
like that i just
okay so i really like i like the company
i like the company
in the presence of a man a woman will be
a woman
and the presence of that one more time
in the presence of a man
a woman will be a woman will be a woman
and
when you know you get you know these
disrespectful women
i i just believe that you know they're
being disrespectful because they don't
respect
the man presence they're in they don't
respect his presence
yeah you know i mean you're you're
you're you you all you want to do
is what other dudes want to do you want
to get between them legs that's it
regardless on because you see that
you know there's a different woman that
you know that's that's here
now like they're just a different woman
but the nature of a woman don't don't
change they still want to be taken care
of they still want to be led you know
what i'm saying
so you have to be a leader you have to
you know get
get those things masculinity has to be
out front
like you know i'm saying it has to be
out front for her to
want to respect you to want to be that
woman in front of
and uh you know you can't always just
want to have sex with
um guys if you made it this far brothers
and sisters comment down below hashtag
bring
back nasheed why because we want to
bring this brother back for a second
interview
this was so beneficial bro for making
the time we really appreciate it
if the two brothers don't have anything
to add let's send it off
no all i was gonna say is that we need
to have an episode or two on games
specifically
uh yeah we want to do that we want
another episode maybe even on like
something parenting too
you want to hear from uh from a dot bro
yeah oh
yo i'm hard with my [ __ ]
all right i gotta make some i gotta get
into hudson mcdo
man like forever you know i mean they
they're really good kids like they're
really good kids i think i taught them
good morals or whatever but
like they gone from the dean man they
don't
especially my sons like they don't
and they'll bring them back guys anyone
watching makes them do our two bro
just like brother nasheed father made
dua the most powerful man that was if
any no no other takeaway that's the
takeaway for this episode that
dua is truly underrated yeah it's
prescribed for us for a reason right so
make some dua that
you know brother nasheed has peace his
kids are guided to the truth
everyone around him including himself is
on dean i mean and
rami ended up all right with that being
said jazakallah for an amazing episode
we do appreciate it we hope to have you
back soon insha'allah
everyone remember to comment like
subscribe and to share the video because
this was definitely a very
real episode masha allah make sure to
check out our patreon and the brothers
books
in the description with that being said
allah
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively
more than you're influencing them
positively i think you need new friends
[Music]
[Music]
hmm